And here's the code that we use to do that.
Now, you might remember formattedName from before.
And we added formattedRole.
Now, to create our formattedRole, we took HTMLheaderRole.replace,
and we replaced the data placeholder with the role that we created up here.
So, this next bit of code is a little bit tricky.
So, over here we have our header div.
We can see that header already has an unorder list inside of it.
So, if we append the data, it would actually put the data right here.
We want it to show at the beginning of our header tag, right here.
In order to add elements to the beginning,
we actually need to use prepend instead of append.
So, we want our name to appear first and our role to appear second.
So running through this code, when we append our formattedRole,
it'll show up at the top here.
And then when we prepend our name, instead of showing it
at the end as append would, it will insert it in the beginning.